Dear Jesus, may I enter into the eternal divine order of God to place my absolute nothingness
in the heart of the most holy Trinity, to give to my God the joy of fulfilling the
purpose of my existence by doing all the acts of my life through the immaculate heart of
my mother Mary and in the divine will of God.
And in this same manner may I live, pray, act, eat, walk, sleep and do everything.
May my soul be devoid of any other longings, wants or desires, and may you, my beloved
divine will, do with me whatever you want or desire.
All I ask is that you bind me to your most holy will so intimately that I may never
swear from carrying out what I know to be your good pleasure.
And that I remain so docile to the movements of your divine will that you never perceive
even a breath of resistance in my soul to your requests of me.
Come divine will with all the angels and saints, especially my sweet mother Mary, to touch
my forehead, to imprint on it the Holy Spirit and infuse in me true light, so that I may
understand the truths and the good that are in these writings and prayers, amen.
We start this evening with November the 6th 1926, and we're starting with the wonderful
message about the new divine will apostles that Jesus wants to raise up.
So Louisa begins by saying that she was feeling all oppressed under the weight of the privation
of her sweet Jesus, oh how I longed for the celestial fatherland she said, if which I
will no longer lose sight of him, I will no longer be subjected to the hard martyrdom
of feeling myself dying without dying.
Louisa was very extraordinary in so far as she couldn't wait to die and go to heaven.
Most human beings are afraid to die because they're not so sure of their destiny on the
other side.
Louisa was very sure.
Now she said, while I was tired and exhausted of waiting my sweet life my dear good, my sweet
Jesus moved in my interior, but he was all afflicted, and it seemed that he was sending
chastisements over the earth.
Now the next bit I think is very, very lovely, but in order not to give me more pain he didn't
want me to see them.
He knows that she goes wild when she sees the chastisements, but from the way I saw him,
she said I understood the chastisements, Louisa is looking at Jesus long enough to know every
single expression, every movement, and so she gets the message anyway, it's just that
she doesn't see the disasters that are actually happening on the ground.
And sighing Jesus told her, my daughter courage, let me finish manifesting to you what is necessary
regarding the kingdom of my will, so that nothing will be lacking in order for the kingdom
of the divine will in the midst of the human family to actually be established.
And then after that he said, when everything is complete, I'll quickly take you to the
fatherland.
In other words, I can't take you until the job is done.
You're the one that we have chosen to work with to establish the kingdom of the divine
will, and you have to hang around until the job is complete.
Louisa realizes she has to stay around for a little while longer.
Unfortunately, this is only volume 20.
If she knew that there were 16 more volumes to go, I think she might not have had a good
day.
It's just as well that we're not told too far in advance of what's coming.
So Jesus said to her, do you think you're going to see the full triumph of the kingdom
of the Supreme fiat before coming to heaven?
It is from heaven.
He said that you will see its full triumph.
The same thing will happen to you as happened to me in redemption.
He said, I did everything that was needed.
I formed the foundation I gave the laws and the councils that were needed.
I instituted the supplements.
I left the gospel as the norm of their life.
I suffered unheard of pains on to death.
But while being on earth, I saw little or almost nothing of the fruits.
A tree takes time to mature.
And he himself said that the kingdom of heaven was like a mustard seed that was planted in
the on fertile, hostile environment of the Roman Empire.
So he said, while I was alive, he's merely trying to console Louisa as to why she's not
seeing great things happening.
After I had done everything and there was nothing left to do, I entrusted everything
to the apostles.
Now, what was going to happen about this entrusting the divine will?
Okay, I left everything to the apostles.
He said that they might be the town criers, we would say, or the heralds of the kingdom
of redemption, so that the fruits of the works that I did in redemption would come out.
So he's now introduced the topic and in the next paragraph, we have the new apostles of
the divine will.
The same thing is going to happen in the kingdom of the divine will.
He said, we'll do it together.
Louisa can't do it on her own.
John 15 five without me, you can do nothing.
So we will do it together.
And my daughter, he said, your pains, your long sacrifices, your incessant prayers that
my kingdom will come soon and my manifestations about it, he said, I will unite everything
together with me and will form the foundation.
So Jesus is doing all the work, even though it looks like Louisa is doing it.
And once I have completed everything, he said, I will entrust the kingdom to my ministers.
We are the priests of the church.
So that like second apostles of the kingdom of my will, they will be the heralds or the
town criers of the kingdom of the divine will.
Do you think that the coming of father, the Francia, who showed so much interest and who
has taken to heart the publication of what regards my will came by chance?
No, no, he said, I had to dispose them.
In other words, we could do nothing.
Without me, Jesus said, you can do nothing.
Jesus says that he chose Hannibal de Francia for this.
And he was an extraordinary confessor to Louisa for a time.
He was the one who gave the informator to the first 10 volumes.
And by the time he died, I think 19 volumes had been accepted.
But the informator was only on the first 10 by the time Hannibal de Francia died, I think.
So do you think the coming of father de Francia was by chance?
He said, no, I myself disposed of it.
It's a providential act of the Supreme will, not as providential.
The church has long since trained its members to divine providence that there's nothing by
chance in our lives.
Everything is by divine providence, no matter what happens, divine providence has permitted
it or directly actually wants it.
It is a providential act of the Supreme will who wants him as the first apostle of the divine
fiat.
So Hannibal de Francia, priest, is the first priest apostle and proclaimer of the divine
will now why would Hannibal de Francia be chosen?
It's because he is all the right contacts.
And since he happens to be the founder of an order, it's easier for him to approach bishops,
priests and people and also within his own institute in order to proclaim the kingdom
of my will.
That's why I assist him so much and I give him special light because in order to understand
my will, it takes great braces, would you please underline that if you're dealing with
your own book at this moment?
In order to understand the divine will, it takes great braces, not little lights.
We don't get this by our natural intelligence.
It takes the sun, that means the source of light, that's himself, to understand a divine
holy and eternal will.
That's the first thing, only God can enable us to understand the divine will.
And it takes a great disposition on the part of the one to whom this office is entrusted.
Now since we're not priests and the priest leaders haven't taken over yet, then I sort
of put us lay people in the position of John the Baptist announcing that the time has come
and pointing out to the church what the Lord wants to do.
But even among us, it takes the Lord's own personal intervention to enable us to actually
understand this text.
We need great graces, we also need the proper dispositions in order to do it, okay?
And then he said, reminding Louisa of what she complained about for at least 10 volumes,
the daily coming of the priest, I myself also disposed.
She kept asking him to stop the priest from coming and he kept refusing and she kept up
asking him.
It was really extraordinary.
He said, I myself disposed that I might find quickly the first apostles of the kingdom of
the divine fear.
You see, if he didn't insist on priests actually assisting Louisa, the church would not have
known that this was a very important revelation.
The church would not have known that it had to get involved.
The church would have done what it has done with other revelations which lay people have
received.
They would have shoved it aside and forgotten about it maybe for centuries.
We know that the revelations of Sister Faustina were simply shoved into a drawer in the Vatican
and they forgot all about them and it was the extremely important introduction to the
kingdom of the divine will that we would go through divine mercy.
And it took somebody to be elected pope to have the authority to take them out of those
drawers and get them out into the people as happened with John Paul II.
So Jesus said that the priests who came to attend her every day was part of his insistence
that the church would get involved from the beginning.
He said, therefore, let me finish first so that after I've completed, I may entrusted
to the new apostles of my will and you will be able to come to heaven and it's from up
there.
You'll see the fruits of the kingdom as he has already told her in the first paragraph.
And the final paragraph of this message then, it is in the divine will we live in the unity
of our creator.
So Louisa said, I continue to do my usual acts in the supreme volition and I talk to myself
by poor mind goes round through the sea, the sun and the heavens.
Now notice when she does rounds, I pointed this out to you before.
She stays with some things, the sea, the sun, the heavens.
She doesn't go through interminable lists like I have seen some people pass around because
it involves the contemplation of the divine will in the sea, in the sun, in the heavens.
So she said, I went everywhere in order to follow the acts of the adorable will.
What he does in creation, but once I finish going around, I always find myself down below
in my heart, exile that the little reflection she's going to make now.
I think it's really, it's funny.
She said, no matter how much my soul sores into the heavens and does these wonderful
contemplations, I'm back in my heart, exile when I'm finished.
Oh, how I would like to remain, at least in the blue heavens, which usually calls the
Asia, we call that space or the place for the planet.
To do the office of a star from my creator, she'd like to join the stars.
You can see what a child mind she has, but I would disappear in the midst of the stars
because I'm neither beautiful nor shining like the stars.
And so they'd put me out, hurling me down to the bottom.
My long exile, she said, even the stars would go rid of me.
But while I was thinking of this, my sweet Jesus moved in my interior and he told me
my daughter, one who lives in my will lives in the unity because the creator is a unity
of three persons, lives in the unity of our creator, who keeps with himself in his unity
the whole of creation, the whole of creation is in the divine will because if it goes out
of the divine will, it simply disappears.
And just as he keeps the creation, so does he keep in this unity, the soul who lives
in the eternal fiat.
So not only is the whole of creation there kept in the unity of the divine will, but
also the souls who are living in the eternal fiat.
And this unity brings her all the reflections of her creator.
Now in the next couple of messages, we're going to be hearing reflections, reflections,
it's not the most wonderful translation you could use because you're going to hear that
the word reflection that's given to us here means the image of her creator.
And it also means the echo of her creator.
I don't think that's a wonderful translation.
So in this unity brings her all the image and echo of her creator as well as his unity
with all creation in such a way that the living image of the one who created her can be seen
in her soul, that's the big new color if you have your own book.
So these reflections of the creator, he's going to tell us that every act we do more
and more of that image is imparted to us until if we reach the completion of what he wants
in our lives, the whole of the divinity will actually be manifested in our souls, which
is almost beyond belief in its incredibility, absolutely better.
But if you go to 2 Corinthians 3 18, you'll find St. Paul saying that as we contemplate
God and he contemplates us, we become like what we contemplate.
And this is what is spoken about here, that the more we contemplate God, the more about
like we become, we become like him.
And he says that in the divine will, as a result of our contemplation of him and living
in the divine will, we become the echo or the living image.
Now, that living image is also what you call a living host, that our whole person simply
becomes the temple of the living God, 1 Corinthians 3 16, 1 Corinthians 6 16, no, you're not that
you are the temple of the living God and the spirit of God dwells in you.
Okay, we become the echo of everything that God is proclaiming to others.
It's really, really fantastic.
So in such a way, the living image, now notice it's not a picture, it's a living presence
just as you have in the sacred host, the living presence of Jesus.
The living image of the one who created her can be seen in the soul.
People can actually detect the presence, the active presence of God in us.
And by maintaining his unity with all, he keeps her in the reflections of all the things
created by him, the word reflections is going to keep repeated, but now that you know what
it means, I won't keep correcting it.
And these reflections form the sea, the sun, the heavens, the stars and all the enchanting
varieties of nature in the depths of her soul.
Now, he started off by saying that all of creation is in him, we are in him.
When we live in the divine will, then the reflection of him and all of creation is in
us.
So what he wants to find in us, when he looks in us, is that he will see the whole of his
creation reflected in us, and the messages are going to be talking about that there will
be the sun and the sea and the flowery earth and everything absolutely inside of us.
In other words, there will be an interior creation, but it is a living creation, a creation that
can actually respond verbally to God and therefore speak on behalf of all of the mute creation
outside of us.
So the external creation is reflected perfectly internally.
When I was very young, I didn't think I was young at the time, but I was.
I remember hearing a most wonderful lecture from a professor of biology in Dublin University
where I was studying science.
And because some of the students in my class had given up going to mass after a couple
of months of science, I asked this professor to speak to us.
And he gave the most incredible talk and just so sorry, we had no way that we could
actually record it.
And he began by saying that the structure that is in the cell of your little finger,
any of your fingers, any part of your body, but he just took the finger as an example.
He said is the same as the structure of the universe outside.
And so he said, what you see in magnitude in the universe outside, you see in miniature
in your own cell.
So it's not for the first time that God is trying to say to us that his creation has
got to be mirrored inside of us.
That the divine will in creation is in us and the divine will in heaven is in us.
It brings it all into an absolute extraordinary unity.
So we become more and more like the one who made us.
Okay.
So he keeps her that is the soul in the reflections of the things created by him.
And these reflections form the sea, the sun, the heavens, the stars and everything in the
depth of her soul.
That's the bit we're emphasizing right now.
The soul who lives in my will placed in the Asia heavens would be the most beautiful ornament
in this Asia vault.
So he's trying to tell Louisa, she has the message backways if she thinks that she would
be ugly by comparison with the beauty of the stars.
He said it's the opposite such as to astonish the heavens and the earth.
She would have all within herself.
Now what this?
What they would see was actually within herself, she would hold her creator.
This is the astonishing tragedy that people are going to see when somebody in the divine
will actually passes over from this earth to heaven that they take their creator with
them because she has in her soul her own creator.
And there she has a heaven, a sun and a sea, everything, but she has them as her own.
How would she lack even the earth all flowery and the sweet singing of the birds, bearer
of the joy and of the harmonious music of our creator because each created thing contains
a divine note.
Now notice the harmony and beauty of the whole of creation and everything fits in with everything
else.
Beauty is actually harmony and order and when we listen to music that is extraordinarily
harmonious.
It also brings a sense of peace and joy to us as well.
Therefore, instead of hurling you down, he said they would aspire to keep you in their
midst because among the many tragedies that my will contains it has the power to portray
all of our works in the soul.
So when the mission of the divine will is completed in us, if we live long enough and
are generous enough and persevering enough to actually let it happen, then all of the
divine works will actually be manifest in your soul.
We like to centralize all of the divine will acts in her and the divine will is not content
unless it sees its own beauty in the soul.
If it doesn't find its echo, its joy and all of itself, it won't be happen.
Okay.
So I want to give you Sam 96 verse 9, worship the Lord in the beauty of holiness which is
living in the divine will.
So let's come to November the 10th, 1926 and here we have that one who actually lived
in the divine will and closes all of creation within herself.
So we're following on from the last message, okay, and she is therefore the reflector of
her creation.
So you can see in that soul the presence and the work of the creation.
Louisa says, my days always alternate between the privations and the short visits of my
sweet Jesus.
And many times he comes like a flash and he escapes and as he escapes, I remain with
the piercing nail, when will he come back and saying, I call him my Jesus come.
Now we haven't had this for quite a long time.
Louisa used to lament like this in the volumes leading up to volume 20, but since we went
into volume 20, she seems to have shifted from that and I hear she is going back to
it again.
She's lamenting his absence and she cries out to him to come back to her as the little
exiled one.
And in case you have forgotten or you've only joined me recently, I want to give you
Sam 63 and Sam 42.
Sam 63 says that my soul longs for the Lord like a dry, weary land without water.
Sam 42 says that my soul is just drying up without the Lord.
I'd like to give you also two Corinthians five versus one to ten where St Paul wanted
to go to God and leave the earth behind.
Then he realized he still had more work to do and so for the sake of his neighbor, he
said he would stay alive.
So she asks the Lord to come back and bring me to heaven and don't leave me in my exile
any longer.
I can't bear it.
But as much as I called him, my calls were in vain.
So what did she do?
See someone lesser than Louisa might fall into the problem of complaining or sinking
into disappointment or some other negative or semi negative reaction, which would actually
set you back, said that what she did was she plunged herself into the divine will and
abandoned herself completely.
That is the solution.
That's the solution to everything for us.
And not only that, but she said, I did my usual acts.
In other words, I didn't allow what I was feeling for the sense of need that I had to
hold me back from the office that I was given.
So I did my usual acts as much as I could going around through the whole of creation.
And my sweet Jesus moved to compassion for my poor soul, which could bear no more, put
out an arm from within my interior, all pity, he said to me, putting out an arm from my
interior, I wouldn't like to think about.
But however, he was indicating that he was there, he hadn't gone anywhere.
He told me, my daughter courage do not stop.
Let your flight in my eternal will be continuous.
Now she's going to come back in the next message and ask him what would happen if she did in
fact stop even for a minute or a day, and he will explain that to her, but not here.
You must know that my will does its continuous office in all creation things, and its act
is distinct in each thing.
So what he's saying here is the divine will is in everything.
If it exists at all, the divine will is there in it.
The reason why it can continue to exist is that the divine will works continuously to
preserve and to enable whatever the creature is to do what it was intended to do by its
creation.
So the divine will is operating all the time continuously in us.
I wouldn't be able to talk to you unless the divine will permitted that this creature could
talk and has got to enable that all the time.
He says that even though there's only one divine will, and he's been telling us for
many volumes, he only has one act.
There are many, many different effects, he said.
Its one act is distinct in each created thing.
It does not do in the heavens, that's what we call space, the place for the galacty, what
it does in the sun, nor does it do in the sea, what it does in the sun.
It does different things, because if it did the same thing, the sun and the sea would
be the same, and everything in the Asia heavens would be the same if it was the same act.
He says, no, no, no, completely different effects in everything, and in us as well.
I mean, for you and I to actually function at this moment, the divine will has got to
do many tragedies inside of us, because all of our organs, in my opinion, are miracles.
My will, he said, has a special act in each thing, and even though I only have one will,
its acts are innumerable.
Now, the soul who lives in the divine will comes to enclose within herself all the acts
that my will does in all of creation, just by the very fact of living in the divine will.
So, she must do what the divine will does in the heavens, the sun, the sea, and everything
else.
She must enclose everything within herself, so that the soul may follow all the acts
of my will, and not only this, but so that my will may receive the requiting act of the
creature, that means the response, the correct response of the creature.
So this is our response of I love you, I adore you, I praise you, I bless you, I thank you,
and so on and so forth.
This is why we actually touch on the various things.
Therefore, he said, if your act is not continuous, my will won't wait for you.
You need to know that we have it from all the generations gone before us, that the time
and the seasons await no man, time continues, the seasons roll on, you might like to hang
on to summer or autumn, but you cannot, you cannot, and he says you cannot get the divine
will to wait for you either because the consequences would be absolutely dire if he did.
The divine will will follow its course, and it leaves in you the void of its act.
This is why she's going to ask how dangerous is it?
It leaves in you the void of its acts and a certain distance and dissimilarity remains
between you and my will.
Now what he's saying here is, if we refuse to do our acts, if we refuse to give the response
to the divine will, then we actually should, that we actually create a void which creates
dissimilarity between him and us, and the whole idea is to bring us back into the full
image that God intended.
When he said in Genesis 1, 26 to 27, we will make man in our image that we would actually
be like God, but it has to be in a wholesome way, not with all kinds of holes in the picture.
So in the next paragraph, we have to talk about returning to this full complete image
of our Creator and the making of this interior universe inside of us.
This is how we become the echo or the image.
Now you must know the great good that you enclose by enclosing is definitely not English.
The great good in which you take on or you embrace by enclosing within yourself all that
my will does in creation.
Okay.
So if we take on into ourselves, if we embrace it, make it our own, then we are enclosing
within ourselves everything that the divine will does in creation, that's massive.
So while you follow the divine will's acts, you receive the reflection that is the image
or the echo of the heavens and the heavens are formed and extended in you.
So what you are contemplating outside of you is created within you.
So you have the external universe that you're contemplating in your rounds and it had the
internal universe being created inside of you.
You receive the reflection or image or echo of the sun.
The sun is formed in you and you receive the reflection of the sea and the sea is formed
in you.
You receive the reflection of the wind, the flower and all nature in some, everything
and all how the heavens that protect, now watch this the way it's put.
The sun that illuminates, warms and second dates, the sea that inundates and forms its
waves of love and mercy and grace and strength for the good of all.
The wind that purifies and brings rain over the souls burned by passions.
The flower of the perpetual adoration of your creator, look at that.
These all arise from the depths of the soul.
And this is why they're called seas, seas of graces.
The image of the creation outside gives an opportunity to talk about what God is actually
creating inside of us.
So while we're not praying for ourselves at all because in the divine will you don't
pray for yourself.
If you pray for yourself you're not really in the divine will.
The divine will is all for God and all for others.
It's completely love, absolutely giving to God the glory and everything that he deserves
and then reaching out to give eternal life to everybody else, so it's all about love.
So if you're still praying for yourself you have a problem.
The perpetual adoration of the creator goes on in the depths of your being, goes on all
night, goes on all day.
So it's very important for us to be aware of this and to tune into it.
And so if the tragedy ever comes to us that the churches are closed to us, don't forget
that you have the presence within you and that you can close your eyes and enter into
that temple of God and give God perpetual adoration.
Nobody can stop it unless they kill you.
And then if they kill you you do it in heaven anyway.
So I just love the flower of perpetual adoration to our creation.
These all arise from the depths of your soul.
Now living in the divine will is in the depths of your soul.
It's not on the surface of your lips.
It's not a case of saying nice prayers.
It's not a case of accomplishing things outside of yourself.
It's a completely interior response to God.
It is the most private mission you can have.
And it means that as more and more and more and more of us join this mission than the true
spiritual church is born and the adoration of the Creator is going on all the time and
all the praise and glory that should be given to God is given to God.
Nobody outside of you can see anything.
And in a way I call this the church of the Catacombs, it can't be seen, it's safe.
Not even somebody living in your house can see it.
It's completely safe, it's very wonderful.
I just love that expression, the flower of perpetual adoration of your Creator arises
in the depths of the soul.
This is why it is the prodigy of prodigies that living in my will is the true triumph
of the Supreme Fiat.
It's the church at its most spiritual, the church at its most grace filled, the church
at its most powerful.
And they will not be able to destroy it because it's completely interior, it's in a different
dimension to what human beings actually deal with, they only know how to deal with material
things.
And so the soul becomes the image or reflector of our Creator and of all his works.
So therefore we return to Genesis chapter 1 verses 26 to 27.
And also Romans 8, 28 to 30, when all explains that Jesus intended to make us full images
of himself.
Look at the word full, nothing missing.
Only when the divine will places in the soul what it can and knows how to do, then does
our will triumph completely, only when we actually allow the divine will to do what it
wants to do and what it can do, then is the glory given.
The divine will wants to see in the soul not only the one who created her, but all of his
works.
The divine will is not content if she lacks even the slightest thing that belongs to it.
Now notice he's looking for completeness, he's looking for fullness, he's looking for
perfection because that's what perfection is, completeness.
The souls of the supreme fear will be our works, not incomplete as in redemption, but complete.
They will be the new Progeses never before seen or known either by the earth or by heaven.
Why do you say or by heaven?
It's because most of the saints in heaven, I know we have some divine will saints in
heaven by now, but most of the saints in heaven belong to the era of redemption before the
divine will was revealed.
So seeing a new generation of the children of God coming back with all of this in their
souls will be astonishing to the saints in heaven.
What will not be the enchantment, the surprise of these very blessed people when they see
the first daughter of the divine fiat enter the celestial fatherland?
How will their contentment, their glory not be, and seeing her carrying her creator with
her?
That is the thing.
You see our blessed mother was the very first that went back to heaven in this condition.
Louisa is the second and others after her to a lesser extent.
So here you have Romans 8, 19, not only all heaven but the whole of creation, everything
goes into absolute festivity and joy.
So she goes into heaven carrying her creator with her with all of his works, the heavens,
the sun, the sea and the flowery earth and all its varied beauties.
They will recognize in her the complete work of the eternal will because the divine will
alone can make such prejudice and such complete works.
It's just such an immense privilege that we should not under any circumstances hold back.
Now in the next paragraph we speak about her blessed mother.
She is the very first one who went back to glory carrying her creator with her.
And so Jesus tells us that the kingdom of the divine will can be called the kingdom of
the virgin as well.
And the children of the divine will be called the children of the virgin and then we have
to be copies of her.
So Louisa said, "Then I continued my abandonment in the eternal fear in order to receive its
reflections, its image, its echo."
And my sweet Jesus added, "My daughter, my celestial mother was the first who occupied
the first place in heaven."
Now I want to give you Mark 1040 for there.
You'll remember the discussion among the apostles that John and his brother got their mother
to ask Jesus, "Could they be first and second in the kingdom on your right and on your left?"
They were the positions of greatest power and authority in a kingdom.
And Jesus said, "It was only for the people for whom it was appointed."
And the people for whom it was appointed was our blessed mother and Louisa.
The first to enter the kingdom of heaven carrying her creator and the second one.
I'm sure the apostles would have gone mad at the idea that it could have been to women.
So my celestial mother was the first to occupy the first place in heaven.
She was the daughter of the supreme volition.
And because she was the first, she has around her a place for all the children of the supreme
fiat.
So around the queen of heaven there are many empty places that can be seen, which can be
occupied by no one else but her copies.
Now this is extremely important.
We have been called into the divine will so that we will become copies of our mother.
And since she was the first from the generation of my will, the kingdom of the fiat will also
be called the kingdom of the virgin.
Oh, how the sovereignty of all creation will be recognized in these children of ours.
Now, these are the ones he calls children, they're not step children, they're not adopted
children.
They're the real children and they're the ones who fit Romans 819 that the whole of creation
is waiting for them.
In fact, by virtue of my will, these children will enjoy indissolable bonds with all created
things because we've just explained those bonds right now.
They will be in continuous relations and communication with them.
They will be the true children in whom the eternal creator will feel honored, glorified
to have them as children.
I think that's an immense statement that God would feel honored to have us as his children.
So that gives us an even greater stimulus to try and reach the fullness of what we are
called to do.
The eternal father would feel honored and glorified to have them as children because
he will recognize in them his own divine will operating which has reproduced his true images.
Now, I'm going to read a little text for you.
I can't hold back, I normally just give you the reference, but I can't give it to you
this time.
I think it's fantastic.
It's one John three versus one to three.
How great is the love the father has lavished on us that we should be called the children
of God?
And that is what we are.
The reason the world does not know us is because it doesn't know him.
Dear friends, now we are the children of God, but what we are to be in the future is not
yet known.
Now, you see, even John, this great fantastic mystic whom I absolutely love didn't know
about what we're reading about because he was in the first century.
All we know, he said, is that when he appears, we shall be like him when we see him as he
really is.
We will be like them.
We will be his true images.
And everyone who has this hope should purify himself and become as pure as possible.
In other words, we should make ourselves more and more worthy of such an incredible gift.
So after this, Louisa said, I was thinking to myself, before sinning, she's shifting to
another topic now, she's going to talk about Adam.
And she's going to wonder, did Adam really suffer from breaking with God?
And she's going to make a comparison between herself hesitating.
Before sinning, my first father Adam possessed all these bonds and relations and communications
with all creation, because by possessing the Supreme will as a whole, it was so natural
for him to feel within himself all these communications, whenever it's operated.
Now in withdrawing from this will so holy, she asks, did he not feel the tearing he made
from his creation, the snapping of all the communications of all the bonds broken from
the divine will as though in one single breath?
And then she refers to herself earlier in Volume 20.
If I just thinking of whether I must do an act or not, or by just hesitating, I feel
that the heavens tremble, the sun which draws, and all creation is shaken, and is in the
act of leaving me alone, not as leaving me alone, so much so that I myself tremble together
with them and frightened immediately without hesitating, I do what I must do, how could
he do that?
Did he not feel this tearing so harrowing and cruel?
Okay, so then Jesus responds to her and he says, Adam did feel this tearing and harrowing,
but in spite of this he fell into the maze of his own will, and this is how we understand
deliberate sin.
You know something is wrong, you know you shouldn't do it, you know the consequences
won't be great, you still do it, but that's the human will that is worst.
So in spite of this he fell into the maze of his will, which gave him no further peace,
either to him or his posterity.
Now if you look at Genesis chapter 3 to 6, I'll summarize the three chapters for you,
chapter 3, 4, 5, 6, 4, chapter, sin increased and multiplied and filled the earth and conquered
it, and the earth had to be cleansed with the flood in chapter 6.
It's incredible.
The speed with which the sin destroyed the earth was just absolutely amazing.
So neither he himself nor his posterity knows what peace is as we only need to look around
us to see.
All creation withdrew from him, why?
Because all creation is in the divine will.
All the animals were in the divine will, they moved away and the strange thing is we call
them wild animals, maybe we should say wild man.
All creation withdrew from him as though in one single breath and happiness, peace, strength
and sovereignty, everything withdrew.
So Jesus is giving her the detail of this incredible tragedy.
Adam remained alone with himself, now to be alone with God is a very wonderful thing,
but alone with yourself is a different matter of God.
For Adam, how much it cost him to withdraw from my will, just by feeling isolated, no
longer surrounded by the courtage of the whole of creation.
He felt such fright and terror, so the kingdom of fear begins, and we're living in a world
that is being governed by fear right now.
He became a fearful man, that means a man full of fear, and fear is Satan's greatest
weapon to destroy us.
Anyone suffering from fear should be told to throw themselves into the arms of their
creator and plus God beyond reason, and you get your peace back and your joy and your
union with God and everything else.
What happened to Adam was that he became afraid of everything, even of my very works, and
with reason, because it is said, one who is not with me is against me.
So that's Luke 11-23, since he was no longer linked with them by justice, they put themselves
against him.
Now you'll read this in Genesis chapter 3, verses 17-19, and also you can go on to the
next section 20-24, because there Adam was told that the earth was no longer going to
cooperate with him.
It was not going to produce the crops that he wanted, it was going to produce brambles
and thistles and so on.
The woman was told that she was going to suffer incredibly, particularly in childbirth.
They were really going to suffer, the earth was going to be against them.
Now we're living at a time when the earth is literally at war with us.
There are terrible floods and disasters all over the world, and we have so many volcanoes
blowing all at the same time, and there are earthquakes every single day.
You'd wonder whether we would get the message or not, that the earth is actually rebelling
against us.
Okay?
So Jesus said that the earth refused to cooperate with him, and it was a matter of justice.
They were putting themselves against him.
For Adam, there is much reason to have compassion for him, and one of the things that you would
never ever think of, you see, the marvelous thing about God, and when we come before him
in judgment, is that he will consider all the mitigating factors.
When you see a huge case going to trial, a good judge will look for all the mitigating
factors so that they can show as much mercy to the condemned person as possible.
Look at this, what Jesus says, Adam had no example of anybody else who had fallen.
He didn't know what to do.
And of the great evil that had occurred to him, so that he might be watchful in order
not to fall, he had nobody to look to.
He was the first.
He had no idea of evil.
This is a very important statement.
Adam was actually innocent of what evil was and his consequences.
Unfortunately, he learned the hard way.
In fact, my daughter, the evil, the sin, the fall of somebody else has two effects.
For one who is evil and wants to fall, it serves as an example, and as a spur, and as
an incentive to fall into the abyss of evil, but for somebody who is good and doesn't want
to fall, it serves as an antidote and a deterrent as hell and defense so that they won't fall.
In fact, seeing the great evil and misfortune of somebody else serves as an example in order
not to fall and not to follow that same path, so as not to find oneself in the same situation.
So Jesus is saying that we have much more help than Adam had.
There was nobody else.
He had no idea what to do next.
So the evil of somebody else causes one to be watchful and to be on their guard.
Mark chapter 14, verse 38, Jesus tells his apostles five times in two sentences to be
on their guard on the night of Gethsemane because all hell was going to be let loose
in Jerusalem.
"Therefore," he said, "the fall of Adam is for you a great help, a lesson and a call.
While he had no lesson on evil, because up to that moment, there was no evil.
Evil didn't exist."
There's a reflection on Adam you mightn't actually have thought of before you read this
text and it shows to me the great mercy of God that he will look for the mitigating
circumstances.
Thank you for coming and we'll share with you again next week.